on passe maintenant à noël noël 91 et la
grande folie des jeux vidéo
les jeunes ne jure plus désormais que
par sony ou super mario pour ne citer
que les plus célèbres de ces personnages
les commerçants eux se frottent les
mains tandis que les autres jouets se
sentent un petit peu seul dans les
rayons l'enquète sur les fêlés de la
console ludovic placé et sergio rosen
tous les ans quelques jours avant les
fêtes les enfants adresse au père noël
en liste de cadeaux cette année numéro 1
des commandes les consoles de jeux vidéo
je donne pour les enfants ce qu'ils
demandent c'est tout effectivement car
pour noël la console à elle seule fait
un bond cette machine hybride compromis
entre les jeux électroniques et
l'ordinateur affranchi du téléviseur a
conquis les enfants entrent mais 90 cm
91 les ventes ont augmenté de 319 %
l'enfer du jeu a commencé dans des
salles comme celle ci désormais écran et
manettes sont miniaturiser les enfants
jouent à domicile
au fil des ans
c'est ma passion
shell comme un compagnon voit pas
comment je suis enfin comme je dis ça
j'ai pas de frère ma femme ça remplacera
s'amusant des lois lane je vous dirais
que moi on veut
tant bien que mal les parents essaient
de suivre le mouvement hormis quelques
grenouilles ont tous apprécié les jeux
et même un peu plus trois petites filles
maintenant je pense qu'on serait à
passionner wii qui m'intéresserait c'est
que mes parents et beaucoup d'argent
mpilé les choses qu'on prend sur la
grosse télé je crois qu'ils très
longtemps je prends pas beaucoup de
devoirs de maths en deux d'école ont
leur un foyer sur trois possèdent une
console
les jeunes passionnés y consacrent en
moyenne une à huit heures par jour
il y a des indices qui ne trompent pas
nous sommes bien en période de noël et à
noël ce sont les enfants qui font la loi
ce sont eux qui font la fameuse tendance
celle que tous kruth fiévreusement à
chaque fin d'année ce qui marche ce qui
ne marche pas un tricheur man batman
tortues ninja et autres créatures
animées bref tout ce qui passe à la télé
dans les publicités
succès garanti pour les fabricants tous
étrangers et puis comme chaque année il
y a le phénomène disney après le film
roi lion les peluches ou à lyon chez les
professionnels on appelle ça du
merchandising
quand on vous dit que les enfants son
maître à bord certains parents le
reconnaissent
des idées absolument fixée précise
chaque noël depuis qu'il est né ce temps
voilà donc c'est particulier mais il
sait exactement
et puis d'autres préfèrent prendre la
flamme à trappes souris c'est quelque
chose qui te plairait d'avoir oui tu
veux le commandé au père noël
oui je veux bien à tous voudraient une
barbie un déjà une 1re h
qu'est ce que c'est ça un ranch c'est
pas mince et des calculs ou là là mais
c'est fabuleux ça et tu l'a commandé au
père noël
en voilà au moins un qui sait ce qu'il
veut les autres hésitent encore entre
les valeurs sûres barbie qui compte 35
printemps et les nouveautés on se les
arrache vraiment beaucoup tous les jours
panoplie batman dans la même série
la batmobile ensuite dans les rayons
fille il va avoir pas mal de couper des
poupées
ou des produits justement qui viennent
pas avec les poupées tout ce qui est
jouets éducatifs premier âge tout ce qui
est donc timbre tout ce qui est décalcos
tout ce qui est atelier poterie etc et
ensuite on a
tous les polypes aux quêtes de mattel
déjoué d'un peu un peu plus petit que
d'habitude qui portait très bien même
produit mêmes effets dans le magasin
spécialisé comme dans la grande surface
les dinosaures sont passés de mode
ce qui marche ce sont les robots les
affreux gags loops et autres caoutchouc
diabolique et dans tous les cas ce sont
les enfants qui choisissent l'argent et
un stage d'équitation
ça fait longtemps que tu ne joues plus
la poupée paris ça fait trois quatre ans
baj lait répandu déshabiller
de l'argent qu'est ce que tu vas faire
avec cet argent je vais acheter des
vêtements pas de joux est une lan décédé
des habits un peu tout sauf des jouets
vêtements chaussures disque c'est le
tiercé gagnant entre huit et dix ans il
n'y a que ça ou presque qui les
intéressent et quand elle entre dans un
magasin de jouets seuls les jeux de
société les travaux manuels perles ou
peinture et certaines consoles vidéo
retiennent leur attention
alors que les garçons du même âge reste
de gros demandeur de jouer en tout genre
ils sont aussi plus influencé que les
filles par les séries télévisées les
garçons bien vont demander vont vouloir
retrouver leur héros à travers les
figurines les véhicules de ces séries
télévisées et puis les filles et bien
elles sont plus mûrs probablement entre
les garçons plus tôt et elle s'oriente
beaucoup plus vite vers la mode donc
vers la mode textile vestimentaire et
puis vers la musique également
le maquillage vers des magazines qui les
intéressent beaucoup plus que les gars
sont bien évidemment les garçons
décidément jeune d'esprit continue à
beaucoup s'intéresser aux petites
voitures il y joue volontiers jusqu'à 12
ans à cet âge là il y à déjà longtemps
que les filles ont délaissé les poupées
même les poupées mannequins dont les
adeptes sont de plus en plus jeunes
elles ont aujourd'hui entre 3 et 8 pour
intéresser les plus âgés barbie a forcé
sa nature elle devient femme active
institutrices ou vétérinaire et elle va
bientôt changer de mensurations pour
être là aussi plus réel pas seulement
femme objet mais sans aucun doute elle
plaira - o papa
le noël 81,18 sera plutôt football coupe
du monde oblige les jeux vidéo consacrée
au football et les baby foot connaissent
un réel engouement comme nous le montre
ce reportage d'eric bestiaux et de
uniflow des champions du monde devant sa
télé ou son pc
ce noël de nouveau jackpot pour les jeux
vidéo baisse du prix des consoles deux
fois moins cher qu'il ya deux ans et
effet coupe du monde conjuguer les jeux
de football talonne la star du genre
lara croft en moins d'un an 3e de foot
ont connu un énorme succès mais beaucoup
beaucoup de jeux sortis sur le foot est
un véritable engouement conduire les
gens ils vraiment envie de jouer mais
pareil comme dans la rue ils ont
ressorti les ballons pour jouer et
l'appareil ont le niveau du jeu ils ont
voulu rejouer sur leur console
[Applaudissements]
enjoy comment arrêter quoi sauf que
c'est un jeu on peut choisir son équipe
son stade et même sa tenue revivre des
moments de plaisir ou de frissons
dans la peau d'un joueur connu c'est
intéressant on s'y croit vraiment mais
c'est bien aussi d'avoir son propre
joueur donner ses propres perso avec ses
propres noms monter son équipe avec ses
potes
tous les scénarios sont possibles même
les plus improbables comme ce but du
brésil contre la france personne n'y
croit
autre lieu autre jeu autre ambiance ici
dans le jura on fabrique des baby foots
depuis des générations
un jeu insensible au mode mais pas à
l'effet coupe du monde
les commandes ont d'ores et déjà
augmenté de 30 % plus qu'une estimation
parce que nous somme on est de descendre
que toute la distribution s'est engagée
et que je constate que les consommateurs
suivent l'enterrement jeux vidéo il est
difficile de s'identifier aux joueurs
avec ces petits bonhommes de plastique
tout se fait dans le même moule 200000
baby foot sorte de cette usine chaque
année des jouets pour s'amuser de 4 à 16
ans passé cet âge les grands enfants
joueront au baby bistrot mais ça c'est
une autre histoire
[Musique]